yes Morty what's your original reality
and where's your rig gosh we moved
around so much it's hard to remember I
see every Rick is my Rick what's this
its secrets well what do you think it is
look at how I'm dressed it seems like a
good time for a drink and a cold
calculated speech with sinister
overtones but speeches are for
campaigning now is the time for action
and this is a Morty who with we're not
just one step ahead of our Rick but one
step ahead of all Rick's the division I
see is between the Rick's and Morty's
that like the Citadel divided and the
rest of us you know everything is saying
is the right thing it's just that he
only said it in order to manipulate an
entire space station of genius
scientists to give him the ultimate
power in the multiverse which is pretty
terrifying to think about what that
protect now is the time for action
everyone so you requested an evil Morty
video so now it's time to talk about
what his grand plan is who he really is
there are a lot of theories about his
secret identity but I think there are
some clues that go back to that first
appearance of evil Morty and things that
the producers have said so if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get everything
there is a new round of the giveaway
I'll explain at the end of the video -
there's like a new Rick and Morty art
book that's really cool that I think I'm
gonna do for the giveaway now but let's
talk about what his evil plan is now
that he's in control of the council then
we'll talk about his secret identity I
don't think it's quite as big of a
secret as people think that it is but
it's Rick and Morty so fan theories go
pretty deep but taking Ryan Ridley's
comments at face value the producers
intend evil morty to be this character
that'll say anything he needs to to get
people to vote him into power so
anything he said during those campaign
speeches should be discounted as
completely false but you say he's a
morty he wants to put Morty's in
positions of power there changing the
curriculum at the Morty's school now and
now everybody's wearing morty pins and
they're wearing those same uniforms like
you see the stand by me Morty's that are
wearing the same uniforms as the sort of
officer Rick's that wore the white
uniforms before so it seems like he's
trying to make things equal between
Morty's and Rick's but you remember way
back to his first appearance he was
responsible for that Giants
fear of tortured Morty's that was hiding
their brainwaves from the council so he
has no problems throwing other Morty's
under the bus when he needs to and
remember his plans there too because as
they pull up Rick makes a comment about
how it's over complicated making me
discount the idea that it's secretly a
Rick inside a body of a Morty pretending
to be evil Morty but that gets a little
more complicated I think they're
positioning evil Morty in terms of grand
plans as the sort of opposing force -
Rick so what is Rick all about he hates
the government are you stupid we're done
with the Citadel of Rick's I was never
on board with it in the first place
that's why I murdered everyone in charge
and left it to rot he's supposed to be
the richest Rick which is why he makes
fun of all the other Rick's that have
joined the council because he says he
hates the government more than anything
else but you Dumbo's hated the
government so much that you got together
in form of your own government and you
became the thing that you hated so I
think it's pretty clear that within the
society of the council things got
complacent and they turned into another
version of the Galactic Federation so
think about our Morty he's slowly
getting smarter and smarter he starts to
see what Rick really does to the family
and how even though he loves him like
there are moments when it's genuinely
touching between them but then they yank
it right back and Morty just getting
tired of all this [ __ ] so he just wants
some stability so the last couple of
episodes he slowly stepped up people
have fallen in line like even Beth had a
little crazy he reined her in it sounds
like evil Morty is from a reality where
he was on a similar arc like that he
slowly stepped up got smarter and
smarter tired of Rick's [ __ ] and then
just went off the deep end because
something between them went down
differently or he came to some different
conclusion than our Morty but as Ryan
Ridley said he's smarter than a lot of
the Rick's so I don't think he's quite
as smart as c-137 Rick so just to be
clear our version of Rick is c-137 and I
also believe that our version of Morty
is c-137 so just remember that right now
the main universe of the show that we're
on is not c-137 even though we do follow
different versions of the characters
sometimes in episodes the typically main
version the one that's experiencing the
divorce storyline is still c-137 Rick
and see
1:37 Morty so that Rick is the ricca
strick and he's the one that points out
as they pull up to this evil base here
that he could have done the same thing
with a couple Morty's and some jumper
cables so just a way to remind you that
even though it seems like evil Morty is
capable of outsmarting c-137 Rick it
doesn't mean that he's smarter and Rick
will eventually figure out what's going
on but obviously because the council
hated Rick before this now things aren't
going to get any better and evil Morty
is aware that our rig outsmarted him
before the title of the finale is the
Rick turian Morty date and it says Rick
has a confrontation with the president
so a lot of people are taking this to
mean that he's going to have a
confrontation with the President of the
Council who is evil Morty but also just
remember that they confirmed that Keith
David was coming back to voice the u.s.
president you know back from the get
schwifty episode so if he doesn't appear
before episode 10 then the president in
the finale the rick has the
confrontation with could be the US
president and worst-case scenario they
don't follow up with evil Morty's plans
till season four but I think we'll at
least find out what's going on but he's
just too good of a character to
completely get rid of in season three so
I think they're gonna at least leave
some dangling thread to pick up on in a
future season but I don't think they
would have done the tag at the end
saying that this will never affect us
talking about all the mermaid poon if
they weren't gonna go back there really
soon and there's only three episodes
left so just to reiterate evil Morty's
in power I don't think that that's going
to change going into season four even
though Rick will figure out what's going
on he's just too good of a character it
it'd be weird for Rick to blow up the
council in the first episode just to
blow them up again at the end of the
season so just be prepared for them not
to completely resolve things going into
season four in as for secret identity
like I said I don't think that evil
Morty is c-137 now it's totally possible
that he's like the prime version of
Morty like c-137 Morty what about a 1
Morty where's he at
but let me know in the comments who do
you think evil Morty is and what do you
think that his grand plan is now that
he's in power what is he gonna use the
council of ricks to do and i know a lot
of you have pointed out that in the
reveal at the end of last week's episode
his patch was on the wrong eye that
might just be a continuity
and yes you know a lot of you have
pointed out there are a lot of fascist
overtones I agree with that you can take
anything you want to from this it's
basically someone using conflict to
seize power making weak people feel
strong so there are a lot of parallels
to real world despots that you could
draw to that but what will happen is
they'll be new Rick and Morty this
weekend leave all your bonus video
requests in the comments below
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner a loo card to D please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get my contact details you want
a copy of that art book and there is a
new round in this video all you have to
do to enter is just be a subscriber or
leave a comment on this video I'll
announce the winner when I post new Rick
and Morty and to answer your question
yes there will be a season four but
they're probably not going to officially
say anything about it for a while
click here for the trailer for next
week's episode and you can click here
for all my other Rick and Morty videos
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]